Ціна на електроенергію для українців могла зрости майже учетверо,
якби Верховна Рада не заборонила будівництво
домашніх сонячних електростанцій на землі.
У цьому запевняє міністр енергетики та вугільної промисловості України Ігор Насалик.
Міністерство надало можливість до 50 кіловат
генерувати індивідуальникам.
Але, вибачаюсь, вони генерують для себе, а не в ринок.
Якщо б ми це не захистили, то нашим споживачам треба було б платити
не по гривні нуль шість, а по чотири гривні.
DW перевірила:
Завдяки "зеленому тарифу", тобто пільговій ціні
для відновлюваних джерел енергетики,
який в Україні є одним з найвищих у Європі,
країна дійсно переживає бум охочих заробити на сонці.
У сонячну енергетику активно інвестує і великий бізнес,
і приватні підприємці.
Хоча частка енергії, яка виробляється з відновлювальних джерел,
все ще залишається мізерною - менше 2% всієї генерації.
Для порівняння - у Німеччині на відновлювальні джерела енергії
припадає понад 40% від загального обсягу струму.
За даними міністерства енергетики України,
щоквартально кількість домогосподарств, які встановлюють домашні сонячні електростанції,
зростає на третину, і нині їх в Україні - понад 7 з половиною тисяч.
При цьому у відомстві нарікають, що багато українців
встановлюють станції не для власних потреб,
а лише щоб продавати енергію за завищеною вартістю.
Утім, домашні сонячні електростанції -
це лише близько 6 відсотків від усіх "зелених" електростанцій.
Загальна їхня потужність - 157 мВт.
Тоді як потужність, приміром, лише однієї великої
сонячної електростанції у Нікополі, яка належить бізнесмену Рінату Ахметову,
- 200 МВт. Тобто одна станція продукує
більше струму за всю домашню генерацію
І саме великі проекти відновлюваної енергетики
мають надлишкову потужність, зазначають економісти,
і є головними отримувачами доплат з бюджету за "зеленим тарифом".
Якщо поглянути, які суми припадають на різних учасників енергоринку,
то виявиться, що домашні сонячні електростанції,
за підрахунками українських експертів,
заробляють близько 900мільйонів гривень нарік.
Це приблизно пів відсотка від усіх грошей на енергоринку.
Водночас на промислові "зелені" сонячні та вітростанції
припадає 15 мільярдів гривень або 8%.
Тариф у 4 гривні, яким лякає міністр Ігор Насалик,
- це вартість сонячної електроенергії,
яку виробники продають у мережу за "зеленим тарифом".
За логікою урядовця, чим більше такого струму в об’єднаній мережі,
тим дорожчим він буде для інших споживачів.
Проте ціни на електроенергію для населення в Україні - регульовані
і встановлюються Національною комісією,
що здійснює регулювання у сферах енергетики та комунальних послуг.
Тому збільшення вироблення струму домашніми СЕС
прямо не впливає на ціну електроенергії для побутових споживачів.
Утім, навіть якби не було регульованих цін, наголошують економісти,
то витрати на купівлю струму у домашніх СЕС
розійшлися би по всьому обсягу споживання електроенергії
і їхній вплив був би дуже незначним - менше копійки за кіловат.
Зрештою можна було би знизити ставки "зеленого тарифу" -
розмови про доцільність такого кроку в Україні лунають дедалі частіше.
Адже він вже не відображає реальну вартість,
яку потрібно інвестувати в будівництво сонячної
чи вітрової станції з точки зору капітальних витрат.
Збільшення випуску електроенергії домашніми СЕС
прямо не впливає на ціну електроенергії для побутових споживачів.
Адже в об’єднаній енергетичній системі України
діє єдина система тарифів, які встановлює профільна Нацкомісія.
Тож, заява міністра енергетики Насалика
дещо перекручує факти.
Домашні сонячні електростанції
наразі мають мізерну частку на енергоринку
, як наголошують оглядачі, приносять більше користі
для енергосистеми, аніж шкоди.
Адже розвивають середній клас
та стимулюють підприємців заощаджувати "зелений" струм,
щоб продавати надлишок електроенергії.